WITH.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE ME WORKING
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP TO MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE I DON'T
GIVE A [BLEEP].
>> CONGRESSMAN, THIS HAS BEEN A
LONG TIME EFFORT ON YOUR PART TO
GET TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT.
I HAVE IT RIGHT HERE.
OVER 500 PAGES.
I HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE TO READ
IT ALL, BUT I WILL BEFORE MY
SHOW TOMORROW NIGHT.
YOUR TAKE, CONGRESSMAN?
>> WHAT IT'S DONE, IT'S
VINDICATED TRUMP ON BOTH PRONGS
OF THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRAT INSPECTOR
GENERAL SAYING COMEY SHOULD BE
FIRED.
I THAT SAID AND YOU BELIEVE
THAT.
THE IDEA YOU WILL HAVE AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE TRUMP
FIRED THE FBI DIRECTOR WHO THE
IG ACKNOWLEDGED HAD NO BUSINESS
BEING THE FBI DIRECTOR IS A
FARCE.
AND THIS SO-CALLED COLLUSION
NARRATIVE, THEY DIDN'T GIVE THAT
TEXT MESSAGE TO THE CONGRESS
WHEN WE ASKED WHERE STRZOK SAID
WE WILL STOP TRUMP FROM BECOMING
PRESIDENT.
6 DAYS EARLIER HE OPENED UP A
COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN.
THIS WHOLE THING IS AFFECTED
WITH BIAS AND IT NEEDS TO STOP.
>> CONGRESSMAN GATES, WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT HE SAID, ONE OF
THE DAMNING TEXT MESSAGES HAD TO
DO WITH STRZOK SAYING DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT.
WE WILL STOP IT WHEN ASKED DO
YOU THINK HE WILL EVER BE
ELECTED PRESIDENT?
THAT INFORMATION WAS NOT GIVEN
TO CONGRESS.
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO DO
ABOUT IT BESIDES GET ON A SHOW
AND COMPLAIN ABOUT IT?
>> FRANKLY, I THINK WE NEED TO
IMPEACH ROB ROSENSTEIN.
THESE TEXT MESSAGES THAT SHOWED
THERE WAS AN EFFORT NOT ONLY TO
REFLECT BIAS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT BUT TO MANIFEST THAT
BIAS IN A WAY THAT IMPACTED
PEOPLE'S OFFICIALACS AS
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES IS
REPREHENSIBLE.
THIS WAS BACKFIELD OUT.
-- BLACKED OUT.
IT WAS EMBARRASSING TO THE FBI
THEY HAD SWAMP ALLIGATORS DOING
EVERYTHING TO BE DESTRUCTIVE.
>> WHAT IS FRUSTRATING WHEN THE
VIEWERS WATCH THIS AND LAST
NIGHT I WAS ON SEAN HANNITY'S
SHOW WHEN HE WAS HOSTING.
IT'S SO SAD.
I ALWAYS BELIEVED IN THE SYSTEM.
CAN AMERICANS BELIEVE IN THE FBI
BASE UPON ON THE FACT IT SEEMS
LONG-TERM DAMAGE HAS BEEN DONE
TO THE INSTITUTION?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST STRZOK AND PAGE.
THERE WERE OTHER FBI AGENTS.
ONE SAID AFTER TRUMP WON WHO WAS
PART OF THE HILLARY
INVESTIGATION AND PART OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION, HE SAID,
VIVA LARESISTANCE.
THIS IS A GUY WORKING WITH
MUELLER?
GIVE ME A BREAK.
YOU ALSO HAVE ALL OF THE LEAKING
IN THE REPORT.
SHOWING THE CASCADE OF LEAKS.
YOU HAVE AGENTS GETTING GIFTS
FROM REPORTERS.
THERE ARE BROAD PROBLEMS IN THE
HEADQUARTERS THERE.
>> EVERYONE IS FRUSTRATED.
WE KNOW IT'S WRONG.
WE KNOW JOE WOULD BE IN JAIL.
BUT IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
>> HERE'S WHAT I WOULD SAY.
THE TEXT MESSAGE.
EITHER ROB ROSENSTEIN KNEW THAT
TEXT MESSAGE HAD NOT BEEN
PRODUCED.
IF THAT'S THE CASE HE NEEDS TO
GO.
OR HE WAS NOT CONFIDENT ENOUGH
TO GET US THE INFORMATION WE
ASKED.
HE SHOULD GO.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND CONGRESSMAN GATES, I HEARD
EVERYBODY SAY ROSENSTEIN SHOULD
BE GOING.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT?
>> WE NEED TO FILE ARTICLES OF
IMPPEACHMENT.
THIS IS THE SAME ROB ROSENSTEIN
WHO SAID.
>> WHEN?
>> IMMEDIATELY.
>> WHAT DO YOU NEED?
>> 218 VOTES IN THE CONGRESS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE COURAGE TO
STAND UP AGAINST THE DEEP STATE
THAT IS WORKING AGAINST OUR
PRESIDENT TODAY.
WHAT DOES PETER STRZOK STILL
HAVE A JOB?
STILL AN ALLIGATOR CRAWLING
AROUND IN THE SWAMP OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.?
WE HAVE TO GET RID OF HIM.
THE FACT WE HAVE NOT SHOWS A
LOCK OF LEADERSHIP FOR THE FBI
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> HE MIGHT BE COOPERATING?
BUT I SAY TO MYSELF, WHO IS HE
COOPERATING WITH?
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT.
I WOULD SAY YOU HOLD THESE
PEOPLE IN CONTEMPT.
IF THEY DON'T PRODUCE WHAT WE
WANT YOU MOVE TO IMPEACH THEM
AND REMOVE THEM FROM OFFICE.
IF WE ARE NOT GOING TO USE THAT
POWER, WE WILL HAVE THE SAME
STUFF WHEN WE COME ON YOUR SHOW
AND COMPLAIN AND DON'T GET ANY
RESULTS.
WE HAVE TO USE THE POWER WE
HAVE.
>> CONGRESSMAN, WHAT GATES JUST
SAID WAS WE NEED OVER 200 VOTES
FOR AN ACTUAL IMPEACHMENT OF
ROSENSTEIN.
EVERY TIME SOMETHING COMES OUT
WE SAY THIS IS ANOTHER REASON TO
IMPEACH HIM.
>> IF YOU HAVE A SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE EXERCISING LEADERSHIP AND
THE MAJORITY LEADER AND THEY SAY
ROSENSTEIN HAS TO GO, THEY COULD
MARSHALL THE SUPPORT OF THE
CONGRESS.
IT WOULD NOT COME TO AN
IMPEACHMENT.
WHEN YOU LOSE THE SUPPORT OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERSHIP IN A
POSITION LIKE THAT, YOU CAN'T
GO.
IF WE PUT A RESOLUTION ON THE
FLOOR SAYING ROSENSTEIN SHOULD
GO AND THAT PASSED HE WOULD BE
DONE.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO EXERCISE
LEADERSHIP.
>> WHY ISN'T PAUL RYAN DOING
THIS?
>> HAVE HIM ON YOUR SHOW.
>> I WILL CALL HIM TOMORROW
NIGHT.
FINAL QUESTION, IN TERMS OF THE
FBI, DOUBLE THAT CHRISTOPHER
WRAY WHO WATCHED THIS AND DIDN'T
TAKE
TAKE A WRECK
WRAY WHO WATCHED THIS AND DIDN'T
TAKE A WREC
TAKE A DAEC
TAKE A DAMA
TAKE A DAMAGE
TAKE A DAMAGE D
TAKE A DAMAGE DON
TAKE A DAMAGE DONE
TAKE A DAMAGE DONE B
TAKE A DAMAGE DONE BY
TAKE A DAMAGE DONE BY CO
TAKE A DAMAGE DONE BY COME
TAKE A DAMAGE DONE BY COMEY.
>> CHRISTOPHER WRAY NEEDS TO
IMMEDIATELY FIRE PETER STRZOK
AND TAKE SWIFTER ACTION.
I BELIEVE CHRISTOPHER WRAY
UNDERSTANDS HOW DAMAGING THE ACT
OF THE ANTI-TRUMP PEOPLE WERE TO
THE FBI.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
DOCUMENTS THAT GET TO THE ROOT
OF THIS.
THE ROOT IS RUSSIA.
THEY WANTED TO GET RID OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
THEY WANTED TO LAUNCH A PHONEY
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
I DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
ANYBODY UNTIL THE DOCUMENTS ARE
TURNED OVER.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH NOT GETTING
RID OF STRZOK, IF HE IS